there's a story I've been meaning to
mention of course we know by now that
the American Health Care Act failed
miserably after being pulled last week
it didn't even get to a vote but in the
lead up to that embarrassment Donald
Trump met in the White House with 30
lawmakers to talk about how the American
Health Care Act would impact women's
health issues great thing to do right
vice-president pence seemed to think
that it was a good thing he tweeted out
appreciated joining the president for
meeting with the freedom caucus again
today this is it passed the bill then
Planned Parenthood tweeted a picture of
the meeting saying here's the picture of
the leaders negotiating away birth
control maternity care and abortion
notice anything pointing out that it is
Donald Trump and 30 men in the room men
in a room figuring out women's health
now you could make the case that these
30 men plus Donald Trump are uniquely
qualified to figure out what's best for
women's health blah blah blah we
shouldn't judge just based on identity
but what came out of the meeting was
terrible for women they were talking
about possible amendment to the aaha
that would allow states to take away
health insurance from women who don't
find a job within two months of giving
birth bigley tremendous for women right
the other proposed quote solution that
they discussed would be to take things
like mammograms and maternity care off
of what are called essential health
benefits because in the eyes of
Republican men at least all life is
precious young Patrick from the moment
of conception but mere seconds after
birth maternity and prenatal care are
unnecessary or I guess immediate
postnatal care are unnecessary burdens
on the system I'm not of the opinion
that men can't share their beliefs when
it comes to abortion and audio ception
some people take issue with that for
some reason I don't seem to get that but
when you're having a discussion like
this it's important to get the women in
the room especially when everything that
comes out of it would be terrible for
women and if you've ever needed more
proof that the entire concept of pro
life is a sham and we had no shortage of
proof already it's that yet again after
the kid is born every
buddies on their own including the
mothers and the other aspect of this is
that like with most so-called fiscally
conservative Republican policies they're
not actually fiscally conservative
because maternity care is widely known
to save money in the long run and it get
back gets gets back to the pro-life
example that I've been telling you for a
while if you're pro-life and you want to
reduce the number of abortions giveaway
birth control for men and women and do
comprehensive sex education there's a
great case study that shows that that
reduces abortions but Republicans don't
want to do that and there's also a good
case study which shows that expanding
maternity care also would be a big cost
savings there's a North Carolina study
which found that for every dollar you
spend on maternity care you generate
just over two dollars in savings further
on down the line because as we know
preventive medicine is much cheaper than
reactive medicine male Republican
Senator Pat Roberts was asked later in
the day if he supports the list of
essential health benefits from Obamacare
and he responded with just a hilarious
joke Pat I wouldn't want to lose my
mammograms total clown right yeah it's
no surprise that the freedom caucus
which is the folks in Congress who are
on the furthest right are having a tough
time appealing to women and yeah there
they don't even really seem to care that
much about bringing women to their side
which is something that I I still don't
understand because you know women are
allowed to vote and I know they know
that because they know Hillary Clinton
voted and they voted against her she
voted for herself obviously so they must
know women can vote you think they'd be
trying to appeal to them I think it
partly has to do with the fact that
women are underrepresented in Congress
but in a group of 30 people you can get
one woman in there at least at least the
token woman right at least make the
effort to have someone you can point to
that was in the room today's program is
made possible in part by gamefly which
is sort of like Netflix for video games
they've got over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can also stream games you don't even
need again
in console or a computer because you can
stream games through your Amazon fire
stick or Roku box and then use your
mobile phone as the controller you can
play as many games as you want for one
monthly fee and if you find some games
you want to keep you can buy them for a
low used price never with due dates or
late fees and our audience can get a 30
day free trial at gamefly offer.com /
tdps the games are shipped directly to
you with return envelopes included no
contracts and you can also stream the
games I think I mentioned that you can
also rent games through the mobile app
get a free 30-day trial for david pakman
show viewers and listeners and support
our show at gamefly offer.com /td PS